my brothers and sisters. So, let me end
it with a clip about the Bible and its
preservation.
We're done.
And then we're going to go watch the
debate.
They're not there. It's formal
formality. So, don't leave yet. We're
done.
Williams is debating who, dude? Oh my
goodness. You kidding me?
This guy again? Are you that desperate,
brother?
We're done. But, let me show you this.
Okay.
Daniel Wallace is considered one of the
most knowledgeable foremost
evangelical scholars on the text of the
Greek New Testament and its
transmission.
Remember what I said yesterday?
I watch this. Listen, and watch he's
going to confirm what I told you
about the preservation of the Bible
and the manuscript evidence. But, let me
find the timestamp. We're done.
I'm done with Staffy now, guys.
We're done with Greggy.
7 minute 14 seconds. Watch here.
Watch
the amazing evidence God has given you
your Bible's preserved.
Okay? Listen.
Right here. Let's go right here.
Listen. Wow. Okay. So, what's kind of
interesting about the date of this? This
is somewhat, not exactly, but somewhat
contemporary with someone like Muhammad.
And obviously, we've been doing a lot of
stories about the Islamic view of the
the New Testament. And it doesn't
actually say this, which I found
interesting in the Quran, but people
from the Islamic world say, "Well, your
Bible has been corrupted." Um now, you
have these uh
these manuscripts and others. And maybe
this is a more 30,000 ft perspective.
But, do these older than Islam
manuscripts validate or invalidate the
Bible that we have today? Listen. Oh,
the older ones in particular, but we
have later ones as well that really
affirm the Bible that we have today.
Listen. The difference between the King
James Bible or the New Testament really,
because the Old Testament is almost
identical in terms of the the the basis.
The difference between the King James
New Testament and modern translations,
the Greek text that stands behind those
two is about 5,000 differences. Jared,
go go go see how many words there are in
the Greek New Testament.
All right?
Over 100,000 words. There's an exact
count.
Among the Greek manuscripts that the
King James translators used, with these
earlier Greek manuscripts that modern
versions use, only 5,000 differences and
it has to do with a conjunction like
either the word and and the. Listen.
The vast majority of which cannot even
be translated. There's spelling
differences, there's little
conjunctions, like there's different
ways to say and in Greek and
uh there's all sorts of things. The vast
majority cannot even be translated.
What's Do you understand what that
means?
The majority of those differences
have nothing to do with the text,
its meaning. It has to do with either
the word the.
Should the word the be there or not? And
that's it.
That's it.
But now watch.
Has the message been changed by the
differences and are the doctrines
different? Listen.
Listen to how God has preserved the
words.
What's significant also is that in the
last 400 years, not a single theological
point, no doctrine has changed as far as
I know for any denomination, in
seminary, any Bible college,
uh any uh theological group between the
King James and today. Do you understand
what he's saying?
From the King James to modern versions
and all the latest discoveries
of manuscripts
that were found in 19th century, 20th
century,
none of those manuscript discoveries,
none of them,
the ones they found 19th century that
are earlier,
come from what he calls the Alexandrian
stream.
None of them change the theology,
Christology of the Bible. So, you can
read a copy of John written in the 3rd
century, a copy of John 9th century,
same theology, same gospel, same Christ.
See? Now, you have these King James only
people that speak about the differences,
but they have yet to show anything where
our views are different based on the
Greek text.
>> Now, watch.
>> These modern translations are just
showing us an earlier text. The King
James was based essentially on nine
Greek New Testament manuscripts that had
been published 100 years earlier.
And
the oldest goes back to the 11th
century. So, just 600 years earlier than
the King James, 17th century, 1611.
The oldest manuscripts we have today go
back to the 2nd century. Jared,
we have found copies
of the New Testament books
that go back as early as the 2nd
century,
whereas the books written in the 4th
century.
See that?
30 seconds, we're done. Listen. See
that?
And this one, the 6th century
manuscript, is one of the early ones, a
very important one, and it agrees
substantially with those earlier
manuscripts. You know, I could talk to
you for a long time. This stuff
absolutely fascinates me. We're going to
obviously have to have you back on, my
friend. Guys, we're done with Stafford.
I'm done with Isaiah 6. If you
understood the arguments,
you learn the arguments, master the
arguments, and the material,
you will destroy Jehovah's Witnesses,
Stafford and his cult, modalists,
Unitarians, and Islam.
The true God of the Bible is the
Trinity. Jesus is God almighty in the
flesh.
Distinct and separable from the Father
and the Spirit, the God-man.
Rose physically, he's alive with a turn
physically.
There is no way to get around it if you
believe the Bible. So, with that said,
guys, pray for me. Again, I want to
thank you. Thank you, brethren, right?
Pray for me.
I want to thank you. You see what's
happening. Deborah Woodstein, the fat
blob, the dog of Satan is manifesting
right now on the channel. All the sicko
fans and his dogs of Satan who think
they're Christian are there, feeding his
ego, not holding him accountable,
attacking me, smearing me.
And you see
Stafford doing it. God bless you.
Because of your prayers, we're a small
group, but strong enough.
Your support is unbelievable.
Thank you again. Lord Jesus bless you.
My support was more this one last month.
Pray it stays this way so I can be
honest
and not have to prostitute myself
because I won't. I'll stop. I'll just
disappear.
Because the support gives me the freedom
not to fear backlash, not to fear cat-
character assassination, not to fear
being deplatformed, but to do it
truthfully with integrity for the glory
of Christ. Pray my support doesn't drop.
And do me a favor, pray my daughters and
I will be together.
The Lord brings them to me.
I see them grow up. That God gives them
health and me health, see them grow up,
and I die in their arms, and I teach
them the faith, and I love them.
And I leave the support for them.
Pray I get healthier and holier,
practice what I preach, not fall in
scandal.
Pray God keeps this young lady pure and
safe until marriage or release her. And
I love you guys. And remember, Jesus is
in love with you. And remember, Jesus
prayed for you and me. He prayed for us.
And he lives, we will live. May the
blood of Jesus wash us, our loved ones,
my daughters. Holy Spirit fill them,
fill us to love the Father, love the
Lord Jesus, love you Holy Spirit. May
the Queen of Heaven and all the saints
pray for us.
Name of the Father and of the Son of the
Holy Spirit. In Jesus' name,
let me know did this session bless you?
Did it move you in your heart? Did it
make you fall in love with Christ more?
If so, glory to the spirit, I
accomplished my purpose. Let me know in
the comment section. Love you LeBanto,
all of you. Christ is risen, he is
indeed. Rumble. Make Rumble great again.
Maranatha.
Don't hate, I'm getting skinny.
30 more pounds.